13 years ago, I had a little six-inute
video that went viral. It all started
with a simple chart from a study that I
just couldn't get out of my head. Two
economists asked more [music] than 5,000
Americans how they thought wealth in the
US was distributed. [music] Dividing the
country into five rough groups according
to net worth, the top, bottom, and
middle 3 20% quintiles. [music] This is
what they thought the distribution was.
Then he asked people what they thought
the ideal distribution was. And 92%,
that's at least nine out of 10 of them,
said it should be more like this. In
other words, more equitable than they
thought it was. That response was
telling, admittedly, the notion that
most Americans know that the system is
skewed unfairly. But what was most
interesting to me was the reality
compared to our perception. The ideal
was as far removed from our perception
of reality as the actual distribution is
from what we [music] think exists. So,
ignore the ideal for a moment. Here's
what they thought it was again. And here
was the actual distribution. Shockingly
skewed. Not only did the bottom 20% and
the next [music] 20%, the bottom 40% of
Americans barely have any of the wealth.
I mean, it's hard to even see them on
the chart, but the top 1% had more of
the country's wealth than n out of 10
Americans believe the entire top 20%
[music] should have. Mindblowing. 13
years later, this chart is visually
almost the same. Although the
concentration at the very top is
increasingly worse. But let's look at it
another way because I still find this
chart difficult to wrap my head around.
Instead, let's reduce the now 340
million Americans to just a
representative [music] 100 people. Make
it simple. Here they are. Teachers,
coaches, firefighters, construction
workers, engineers, doctors, lawyers,
[music] some investment bankers, a CEO,
maybe a celebrity or two. Now, let's
line them up according to their wealth.
Poorest people on the left, [music]
wealthiest on the right. Just a steady
row of folks based on their net worth.
We'll color code them like we did before
based on which [music] quintile they
fall into. Now, let's reduce the total
wealth of the United States, which as of
early 2026 was $174 trillion, to this
symbolic pile of cash, and let's
distribute it among our hundred
Americans. So, here's that ideal. They
asked everyone about something like this
curve. I've even added actual dollar
amounts to the charts using the latest
data sources available. [music] The
wealthiest folks are about five times
better off than the poorest Americans.
But even the poor folks aren't actually
poor, sitting on roughly half a million
dollars of net worth. We have a super
healthy middle class with a smooth
transition into wealth. [music] And yes,
Republicans and Democrats alike chose
this curve. 92% said this was a nice
ideal distribution of America's wealth.
This is what people think America's
wealth distribution actually looks like.
Not as equitable, clearly, but for me,
even this still looks pretty great. Yes,
the poorest 20 to 30% are starting to
suffer compared to the ideal. And the
middle class is certainly struggling
more than they were, while the rich and
wealthy are making roughly 100 times
that of the poorest Americans and
[music] about 10 times that of the still
healthy middle class. Sadly, this isn't
even close [music] to reality. Here is
the actual distribution of wealth in
America. The poorest Americans don't
even register. In fact, the bottom 8%
have [music] zero dollars. The middle
class is barely distinguishable from the
poor. And what little wealth they have
is mostly tied up [music] in mortgage
debt and car payments. In fact, even the
rich between the top 5 and 20% are worse
off. Only the top 5% are better off. And
how much better off? so much better off
that the top two to 4% are [music]
actually off the chart at this scale.
Heck, the 99th percentile still won't
fit. And the [music] top 1%, this guy,
well, his stack of money stretches at
least 8 times higher than [music] we can
show. Here's his stack of cash restacked
all by itself. So much green in his
pockets, I have to give him a whole
section of his own because he won't fit
on my chart. 1% of America now has
almost a third of all the nation's
wealth. Roughly the same amount the
entire bottom 90% has. The bottom 50%
the bottom half only have 2 to 2 1/2%
which is shockingly up from 13 years
ago. Still pathetic.
The top 1% own half the country's
stocks, bonds, and mutual funds. The
bottom 50% of Americans own a measly 1%
of these investments. 13 years ago, this
restacked column kind of blew people's
minds. But I'm about to take it one step
further. You see, that 40 million
[music] is only the average wealth among
the 1%. But there's a fundamental
oversimplification in reducing the total
population to only 100 [music] people.
If the curve isn't very steep, say
around the 42nd percentile, [music] this
simplification works. Okay, we know that
each of these percentiles actually
represents as many [music] as 3.4
million individuals or more likely 1.3
million households. But it's okay
because it's easy to see the difference
between them moneywise isn't all that
much. We're simplifying things by using
the average and representing this range
with one individual, but there's really
millions of [music] people hidden
somewhere in this single percentile. the
average is somewhere in between the two
ends, a little lower than halfway,
[music] thanks to the downward curve.
Even as the curve gets steeper, say
around the 87th percent, the average is
still somewhere in between two values
that aren't drastically [music]
different from one another. But at the
top of the curve, at the very top 1%,
things are different. We know the
average 1enter has around $40 million
and that the lowest person has around 13
million. But we also know that the very
top is Elon Musk and he's got more than
$800 billion dollars. So the range
involved in the 1% is very very big. If
we'd simplified our population to a
thousand instead of 100 people,
the.1enter would be the highest average
representing 136,000 households. If the
curve was straight, our average 1enter
would be in the middle and our.1enter
would be just 1/10enth from the top. But
the curve is [music] definitely not
straight. And as it bows down, the
average person gets closer to the bottom
along with most of the other people. In
fact, it's brutally exponential, such
that even the 0.01% and the 0.001% move
quite a ways downward [music] from Mr.
Musk. No, even further than that, our
curve is so terribly bent that the
average 1% person is actually way at the
bottom of the 1% range. His 40 million
is way down here with the vast majority
of the 1enters. But there are still
plenty of people with much more than the
average 1%. [music]
So much more it's actually hard to
visualize at this scale. You see, if I
had subdivided the wealth by a
representative 1,000 people instead of
100, the.1%'s wealth is $184 million,
considerably [music] more than the
average 1enter. If we were to divide
each of those people by 10 more, the
0.01% 01% [music] guy at the far right
has a staggering $971
million, which is $194 of [music] these
columns of cash. More than I can stack
on even one screen. And of course, if we
were to even consider the billionaire
class with an average net worth of $5
billion, that would be about 10 screens
worth of stacked cash at this scale. And
again, that's just the average among the
billionaire class. The top billionaire,
Elon Musk, well, he has more than 1,600
screens worth of stacked bills, more
than $800 billion. [music] So, just to
review, I've rested the 1%'s money to
the right to fit them on our chart.
Because if [music] we keep it in one
stack, it would literally be more than
eight screens tall to get to 40 million.
But remember, that's only the average of
the 1%, which [music] is actually on the
very low end of the range for the 1%.
The.1% would be almost [music]
37 screens high. And the 0.01% at an
even faster climb would still be a
ridiculous
195 screens. [music] For the billionaire
class, we don't have time. It would take
almost a minute to climb that high. So,
I'm fast [music] forwarding ahead. And
for the very top of the chart, we have
to skip again. It would take us more
than 2 hours to climb that high. And
this is just 800 billion, 160,000
screens high. So, the irony is the
original average 1enter that we got so
mad at before, he's actually closer to
the bottom percentile, this guy with no
wealth than he is to the billionaires.
It's a bit hard to fathom. I know. I've
spent a lot of time trying to get my own
head around it, and it still makes my
head and my heart hurt a little. We
really do need to talk about
billionaires. It's painfully clear that
wealth inequality in this country
[music] is absolutely terrible. Yes,
wealth concentration is even worse today
than it was 13 years ago. In fact, it
hasn't been this bad since the guilded
age of the 1920s, [music]
back when words like robber barons were
used to describe the ultra rich. We've
been experiencing outrageous inequality
[music]
for more than 20 years. Here's a fairly
famous chart updated with the last few
years included. It's worse [music] than
ever now, and it's getting worse all the
time. But it doesn't have to be this
way. We've actually been here before.
Back in the 1920s, this level of
inequality led to the worst recession
this country has ever seen. But we
adjusted the top marginal tax rates
[music] to make the ultra wealthy pay
their fair share. We instituted many
other new policies. As a country, we
gained some [music] really great things
as a result. Social Security for one,
minimum wage protections for workers,
half measures in some cases, but still
much needed corrections to [music] a
gross imbalance. Policies that gave more
and more people a lifeline and a real
chance at the American dream. Most
people who saw my old wealth video
[music] just wanted to know how much
worse it is today. And it is worse, just
not in a way that you can easily see
from the basic charts or curves. Those
look about the same, which is obviously
still extremely bad. But the way it is
worse today, 13 years later, is at the
very tippy top. The billionaires that we
weren't even showing in the original
video. The ones that were hidden in our
simplification of 100 people. The
oligarchs now have so much money, we not
only can't fit them on our chart, we
need multiple screens [music] just to
see their wealth. In some cases,
thousands of screens. In a land of
plenty, why should more than half the
country struggle so much just to make
ends [music] meet? Why should the
American dream only be possible for a
small few and an unlikely hurdle for
most? [music] If we're going to survive
the next hundred years or even the next
several decades, we really have to make
things better. [music] It's time to wake
up so we can somehow begin to dream
again.